[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I'm here and guess who
else is here Bryce
Bryce has done a couple talk film
episodes she's now on inside You intro
episode because because Ryan is uh on a
camping trip with his dad
Ryan's over camping trip with his father
something I would never do with my
father
um
yeah a lot going on man um just briefly
I want to thank you for listening if
you're here for Helen Slater you've come
to the right place if you enjoy the
podcast uh we think we're different than
ever any other podcast we talk about
mental health we talk about life with
celebrities it's just not fluff and if
you dig it we'd love your help because
the support really helps us we're not a
huge podcast but we're growing and write
a review subscribe and if you want to
join patreon to help the show go to
patreon.com inside of you
p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com inside of you really
helps the show and uh without the
patrons I I wouldn't be here also the uh
we got the inside of you online store
with tons of cool merch and tumblers
they just got these new inside of you
jackets uh little sweat zip-ups they're
they're dope they're selling out so get
one and uh cool new tumblers and uh
autographed pictures and scripts and
blah blah blah and uh yeah it's a lot of
fun I'll be in Salt Lake City DC and uh
Rhode Island in September with Tom we're
going to do an evening with Michael and
Tom we're going to do a lot of stuff
sign pictures all that I'm on the Cameo
and the inside of you online store cool
merch I said my band sunspin.com uh
we're selling vinyls they just came out
vinyls there's only 99 signed by me and
Rob and numbered
um love the support
you did 99.99 because we we kept one oh
okay yeah yeah actually 98 because we
kept one each gotcha actually 97 because
I gave my mom one there's only 97 96
actually I gave Tom one only 90. yeah
yeah yeah but we appreciate it we worked
really hard on the album and we're
really proud of it and I think you'll be
uh surprised so have a listen if you
will Sun spin we're on Spotify we're
everywhere else and uh we're playing
music
um at the end of every month on
stage.com you can get tickets and listen
to us that would mean the world to me
Our Guest today is Helen Slater
she's been in so many things but she has
so many Fantastic stories about
Supergirl and working with Christopher
Reeve and uh just what did you like
about this podcast I like that she was
open about her experience early because
she came into Super Bowl like what 18
years old or something so she got thrown
into the Limelight super early
um and at a different age right there's
no social media or anything so it's
really interesting hearing that
perspective and then also her her
Fascination and her interest in
education yeah and I think it was like
mythology that she's really into she's
not what you would think from Superman
which is cool she's really smart and
also on top of it what's amazing is she
talks those are my dogs but she talks
about Helen Hunt her best friend and
Helen Hunt you know she tells Helen like
I saw some uh some video of a movie I
did and she's like Helen I look so old
and wrinkly and she was like when she
saw footage and Helen looked at her and
said
sweetheart
we're dying
which is so profound and funny but we're
dying we're all dying we're all getting
old we're all aging when we're born
we're just aging until we end up dying
so I thought that was kind of beautiful
and I apologize for my dogs but I don't
because it's a puppy and all right
without further Ado let's just get into
it let's get inside of Helen Slater it's
my point of view you're listening to
inside of you with Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
I mean I just graduated a myth program
so of course the images and the icons in
this room are totally
fascinating to me
are they just like you just collect what
you want or is there a reason is there
things that I think there's something
that has to do with Nostalgia from a
certain time period of just like going
oh my gosh I remember this moment
with my friend Dave buchert watching
Return of the Living Dead in Louisville
in his basement or I remember my mom
making me watch this movie with her
right and being scared or the first time
I saw the Evil Dead like I always was a
big horror movie fan I've talked about
this but like
it's funny because people assume since I
played Lex Luthor I was the flash I'm in
the Guardians the Galaxy world that oh
I'm I'm big and Marvel and Jesus I know
nothing yeah I heard that about the DC
world when I did Supergirl did you know
nothing nothing did you have to look
into it or you're like no I'm not doing
that well I was 18 when I got the part
and we had much less
access I mean I love Superman
that's a kid that's good
have we started oh yeah oh yeah
we just talk it's just kind of like this
is like you know I like it when it just
like sort of fly on the wall I want
people to feel like they're flying the
wall and we're just two people talking
good you know what I mean now you were
just talking about you you're getting a
degree your Master's in what my PhD I
got my masters last also Masters this is
what I know Masters comes before PhD
right oh okay so it's Bachelor or you
know or whatever what is it 13 years to
get my bachelor's degree because I
started working right out of Performing
Arts High School the fame High School in
Manhattan I just boom got Supergirl that
September after I graduated in June in
1982. so and everything was about I come
from a family where education is
everything and I always just had this
kind of Shame wound around education it
just was like woof my mom went to back
to law school at 42 my brother's an
attorney my stepmother is the first
woman dean of students at Princeton my
stepsisters went to Yale and I mean just
like education is everything so it was
always there and then I just wasn't
working as much and had the time to do
it and slowly made my way through Valley
college right near in the valley and got
the AAA and then graduated from Antioch
and then went to Pacifica Graduate
Institute in their myth program which is
incredible this is a big shout out for
well education I want that program The
Myth mythological you think of like like
like what the Loch Ness monster and
things like I mean are we thinking like
mythological is that what that is I mean
sure that comes from I don't know the
full history of that myth but Greek and
Roman myth World mythology Norse African
mythology
Egyptian we covered as much as you can
for sure we read The Odyssey and The
Iliad and Clyde mestra for sure she was
not very nice she was not very nice I
remember reading those things in college
and you were interesting and I wrote an
album called the myths of ancient Greece
before I even went to school that took
like my six favorite ones Narcissus and
Echo and psyche and arrows and Demeter
and Persephone and
couple of others and and turned them
into like mini musicals because that's
what I had done at performing arts high
school that was kind of my and you have
an album yeah that what's it called the
myths of ancient Greece the myths of
ancient Greece and you think
like who like I'm not this isn't a knock
this is like I what I love is that you
do what you want to do this is my
passion whether or not people really
listen to it I don't think is really
your at some point I think we all have
that kind of pivot of like I actually
want I'm only here so briefly like how
do I bring meaning to this life and how
do you navigate that if the world's not
reflecting it back do you keep going
with that thing that's inside so yeah I
I battle that that thought of like you
know always appeasing always pleasing
always you know a lot of times we live
our lives because you know we want to
make other people happy Mo most of the
circumstances that we're in situations
that we're in so
I think you get to a certain age
hopefully
where you say all right stop
why are you doing this are you doing
this for you are you doing it for some
sort of reciprocated you know
attention is it would it so you have to
really beautiful and and I'm why I'm
working on that I think I'm getting a
lot better I'm sort of like going hey
you know not comparing myself to others
as much like I have a problem not a
problem but I envy those people who I
perceive as having their [__] together I
don't I like them but I'm sort of I look
at them like God why can't that be me
why and I look at you like that because
what yeah I just feel like look at you
you've been married to the same person
since what 89 so that's what 30 I think
we have I can't I think it's there I
don't know well it's a while coming up
to 33 or 35 and every time I've met you
you're just so like you're a straight
shooter but you're very you almost seem
like you're just in a constant state of
uh meditation oh in a good way that's so
that's I will take that one my
dissertation is around has that in it
I'm looking at Refuge practice in myth
and where we see these archetypal images
of Refuge in all myth in all these
different myths how that's such a key
piece kind of what we were just talking
about earlier which is going to get cut
from this conversation but the
importance of kind of collecting oneself
and settling and making sure we're going
to the ocean or hiking the mountain or
doing those things that rest the mind so
that the other stuff can come through
and we can't get to it unless we do sort
of settle back search out those or those
places search us out sometimes we don't
have to be like doing it it comes to us
you you know but I feel like you you've
been like this for quite some time
there's a I'm not saying you're perfect
because you're going to tell me you're
not I'm a hundred percent we can
guarantee of course of course but you
feel like you I feel like you have a
real grasp on
things that are very important things
that I don't think I have a grasp on
which are career
family and love uh you know uh
passions just sort of purpose purpose I
don't think anyone gets out of feeling
same old shitty self as Pema children
the Buddhist teacher says that feeling
of same old shitty self well someone who
is once talking to her that like we have
this we do have self-denegration in
built in which I do too for sure I mean
that is something you certainly writing
a dissertation right now the doubt just
kind of sits on the shoulder and then
there are moments where there's so much
trust like it's okay then there is that
discursive like this is a battle that's
right that we all have we're always
battling with ourselves I mean from the
Buddhist point of view you know pardon
the expression I'm not a professional
Buddhist but I do study it and it's in
my dissertation it's about becoming
friends with or like becoming intimate
with the thing that's just you just want
as far away as possible from yourself
like there's no way I'm accepting that
part of myself and like the Buddhist
view would be not a problem let like if
you open to it you take a seat right in
it it actually shifts and changes it
never stays as that one one concrete
jealous person raging person small
minded you know so is moving through or
yeah yeah I mean that's the Buddhist no
no it's good it's uh
hmm huh just it's just making me think
right now you're making me think what
are you thinking about Michael I'm not
gonna get into it but it's it's just
like uh you know sometimes my mind goes
a certain place when I hear something
that's impactful or why I say certain
things or why I do certain things or act
certain ways and then hearing you
I I guess subconsciously it
responds or
makes me think of things that I do
that I'm like huh I don't know if that's
healthier I don't know if that I should
be doing that or maybe you know I should
be more positive in certain things I
tend to go down sort of a negative place
a lot now it's not a negative place I'm
fun to be around Ryan wouldn't you say I
think it's fun to be here
it's not like I'm a drag but I
definitely you know feel like I can go
down that place where it's like ah this
person this and that that instead of
just sort of like not spending so much
time in that area because it's unhealthy
you know not to be so Jewish with you
but because I'm a born Jewish person yes
there's this have you heard this phrase
about Lush and Hera have you ever heard
that in the Jews come to her is like
keep these so Lush in her is like they
in the Orthodox Jewish circles sometimes
let's say someone's just had a difficult
pregnancy at Birth or something's
happened to a family Lush and her the
community might get together and
practice just not gossiping saying
things out loud that are negative as an
offering for healing that person and
Lush and her to refrain from saying the
thing out loud like it's a really good
like we have a couple of good things in
our tradition yeah that's one of them
yeah I mean that's yeah
inside of you is brought to you by
factor I I have told this story because
it is a true story put me on a polygraph
Factor meals are like uh a godsend
they are incredible meals that get
delivered to my house that are
affordable I save so much money from not
even going to the grocery store and
getting food and then you get food
that's wasted or or Delivery Services
for food
you spend so much money and Factor meals
are not only saving me money but they're
delicious they're delicious and there's
so many options
um they got sent to my house and I
thought it was like someone was just
giving me as a birthday present because
they arrived on my birthday
and I I made the chicken
with mashed cauliflower which tasted
like mashed potatoes with broccolini
and I was just like
why am I not doing this every day for me
it's all about the convenience really if
I can find anything that saves me time I
jump on it when my wife sends me to the
store to buy stuff for dinner I'm an
idiot I walk around the aisles I have no
idea where anything's at it ends up
taking me like an hour but with Factor
meals it's all sent to me I don't have
to worry about wasting time that's true
I love it and not only that we can go
all right honey we're gonna pick our
week's meals what are you in the mood
for how about this how about this great
you know what you're going to get you're
excited to get it boom no shopping I had
that is so true man look refresh your
Healthy Habits without missing a beat
choose from 34 plus weekly flavored
packed dietitian approved meals ready to
eat in two minutes level up with Gourmet
plus options prepared to Perfection by
chefs ready to eat in record time treat
yourself to upscale meals with premium
ingredients like broccolini leeks
truffle butter and asparagus head to
factormeels.com
side 50 and use code inside 50 to get 50
percent off need an extra boost to help
support your Wellness goals and feel
your best for the rest of your summer
try Protein Plus meals with 30 grams of
protein or more per serving round out
your meal and replenish your snack
supplied with an assortment of 45 plus
add-ons including breakfast items like
our delicious apple cinnamon pancakes
bacon and cheddar egg bites bacon potato
and egg breakfast skillet or for an easy
Wellness boost try refreshing beverage
options like cold pressed juices shakes
and smoothies I order the cold pressed
juices I order five for the week it is
awesome this is something I'm going to
continue and I think you should give
this a try this August get factor and
enjoy eating well without the hassle
simply choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor-packed meals delivered to your
door ready in just two minutes no prep
No Mess head to factormeals.com
inside 50 and use code inside 50 to get
50 percent off that's code inside 50 at
factormeals.com inside 50 to get 50
percent off
because sometimes just giving voice to
it constantly can be the bummer like
saying out loud to the person what we
don't like about things or always that
can be the thing that
concretizes it or makes it worse or so
you're practicing refraining then you're
like all right we're just going to take
a pass on that
taking a knock out of somebody taking a
bite out of somebody doing a yeah yeah
it has a good
Source material no I agree with you I
think yeah yeah I'm not gonna you're
gonna be negative no it wasn't a
negative thing it was just I feel come
on let's argue this is Jewish of us no I
just it's not arguing I believe what
you're saying um I I just like I never
talk Politics on the show but I think
that it's just like I feel like it's
unfortunate
that
you know in the last x amount of years
or whatever that we can't have an open
Forum about things in fact it's probably
been there for longer than just a few
years I mean it's been it's sort of like
you know um what do you make of that I
mean isn't it crazy I just can't even
really be in the same room they're my
husband my best friend I have really
good friends they are
there is not two sides there is what is
right and what is wrong and I have
people on the other side that feel the
same way too I mean it is like cuckoo
bird well it's just like can I even have
any conversations and every time you
think of saying something you're like um
I should it's that's what upsets me is
that I'm stopping myself I'm saying oh
right now this is just my two cent
opinion it will pass it'll I think we
could do with a little like let's find
the common ground and not just do the
dump or do this and yet at the same time
we're in this moment movement with black
lives matters and me too where to be
able to call out things when you see it
say it when you you know that's really
important too so I guess we're all it is
and I can speak to you as like a soul
sister as being white and being raised
with Incredible privilege we've been in
such a soup but we
it's sort of like such a learning curve
to even take in these other ideas take
them into heart and then know how to
proceed like I I don't know anyone
that's getting it right I'll just say
this
I don't think it was fair for so many
years for black people Hispanics people
of color to be Typecast or stereotyped
and cast always as this and this and
this for so long and not be given the
opportunities that privileged white
people have had and I hate that you know
old Hollywood that we used to play you
know an Asian character when we weren't
Asian and there was a lot of terrible
horrible things
so I don't mind
at all I'm like I step back and go hey
you guys deserve everything like you you
deserve to be respected and paid
attention to so that's not I don't
that's I don't have any issues with that
at all I think my issues are more with
just like
um you say something and it's you don't
mean to be mean or you don't mean to be
ignorant or you don't mean any you're a
lambasted by certain things I mean
there's just not an educational sort of
like I think because as as a child
I was sort of um no one had patience
with me I was sort of add all over the
place and I wasn't you know I didn't get
an affection or love at home so you know
when I get like somebody yells at me or
tells me you know I don't like that yeah
I don't like to be told you're dumb
you're stupid you can't it's it's a
bigger thing so
I guess it just used to be sort of an
open Forum where you kind of didn't
worry about what you said too much and
now you have to be and it's good to be
empathetic I think it's good to be I
mean the way Rob my husband talks about
it is like it's sort of our turn a
little bit just to be more listening
like he it and that's not an easy thing
to develop if we're used to being able
to just say how we feel or I don't like
that or you know have like it's okay to
just listen for a little while yeah just
to sort of balance it and that's doesn't
come easy no it doesn't but I think
that's the most important thing there is
is listening right whether I mean in in
life that's the number one thing listen
yeah learn understand I mean in acting
101 the number one thing they teach you
is listen right any kind of improv
listen right uh look you have had an
awesome career and you've done so many
things and you've worked with so many
great people I know you went to
performing arts high school I know you
did all these things were your parents
behind that because they weren't you
didn't have actors in your family no my
parents were divorced my dad was an
executive in public television down in
DC my mom was up in New York City
um but she really came out of that whole
uh women's movement when Betty Friedan
wrote the Feminine Mystique and women
burned their bras and were like I am not
staying in a marriage where I don't you
know right she was kind of part of that
and when I lived in Great Neck Long
Island I was surrounded in that soup
before we moved to Manhattan of women of
divorced uh Great Neck was yeah really
unusual Enclave of single women with
daughters really bright brilliant women
kind of finding their way through that
period so my mom's thing more was
almost
so much of you can do anything you want
yeah was it hard
um when did your father I was eight yeah
divorce is hard it was I don't know like
abandonment issues even like
um did you ever notice that you know
it's funny because I'm such I'm a
mythologist now I I have certain images
that come to mind like my brother and I
we're very young I'm younger my
brother's two and a half years older but
from the time we were really little
eight nine years old we were taking the
Subway and then the Train sometimes the
bus from New York to DC to visit my dad
on the weekends without any parental
help that's four hours isn't it four and
a half hours so I have like a Hansel and
Gretel thing like brother and me like in
Penn Station or in yeah that kind of
thing but sure that stuff is a lifetime
of working through of
yeah I don't know and you know I'm
thinking I don't know if you have this
but contemporary friends I'm sure you
have friends that have gone through
divorce and seeing now from the parental
point of view just the Heartbreak of
nobody wants to go through that nobody
wants to put there kids through that
they would never choose to cause that
kind of
so it's funny that it's almost like a
facet of a diamond the different yeah
are your parents still with you my dad
passed away from covid are you serious
that was pretty oh how old he was 86
almost 87. but he was in perfect health
before that not perfect health I mean 87
you're gonna have things was he 86 or 87
let's say 86 April of 2020 so it was
right when it was all hitting and yeah
yeah my mom's still here she's still
living in the same apartment on 86th
Street and York Avenue and wow she's
this very uh she's a political activist
for nuclear disarmament writes on it and
travels used to travel quite a lot and
speak on
speak on peace well shout about peace
as activists tend to do wow yeah
absolutely I mean during cover when your
father passed were even allowed to go to
a funeral nothing we had nothing did you
ever get to celebrate his life and do
anything last summer not this past
summer the summer before we all went to
Maine where we would meet right over the
years and my very close step family just
the per just the immediate family we had
a little Memorial up on the island but
the day he died I mean you hear it's so
interesting hearing when people die like
what happens when they so my brother
figured out because it was covid how to
get an iPad in the hospital room filming
him so it was this is the day he passes
away it was me and my brother on Zoom
with him and my stepmother and we're
just chit chatting I mean just tells you
like when the body is ready to go and
we're talking about being at me in Maine
and I hold up Trader Joe's mango slices
and I'm just saying on the zoom call
with my dad in one frame and my brother
and my stepmom I'm like I don't know
these Trader Joe mango slices are
getting me through covet I don't know
what it is they're just so delicious and
chit-chatting and then we started
talking about being in on the island on
Boston's Main and Chit Chat chit chat
and I look at my father's frame and I'm
like
I don't think dad's breathing and
because it was covid
we had to call my brother had to call
the hospital to get a nurse to go into
the room to see if he had passed away
so it took like 15-20 minutes till the
nurse comes in then she couldn't tell us
because you have to have a doctor she
says can you please just hold a minute
she goes to get the doctor then the
doctor comes in I mean it was wild but
the point being that I know I mean why
wouldn't if you stop breathing doesn't
shouldn't there be like something
no
but that's a good point no one brought
that up but more what I think the bigger
question is is that kind of relaxed
feeling chatting about Maine talking
about mango slices he knew like the
closest people in his and then I felt
like he just thought I can go
huh yeah
I was I mean yeah I'm talking about the
positive but believe there was a lot of
pretty emotional oh at one point my Rob
just like scraped me off the floor and
like took me this is like the week oh
when he first went in because of covid
drove me up to Malibu and we brought
beach chairs and sat along the because
you're just you're not in your right
mind you couldn't get on a plane and I
didn't get on a plane so it's yeah you
know it's what's crazy is I was
Incredibly Close with my grandfather or
Irv was my I mean he was my joy and my
grandmother who's still still with us
and
he had Alzheimer's so I slowly watched
him deteriorate so I was losing a piece
of him yes my dad had some dementia too
and I was losing him before covet that's
such a hard one isn't it it's so hard
and I felt like I still I still to this
day think
I haven't really mourned him and
um I think about him all the time and
sometimes they think about
actually it was so important to your
light in your life
I mean you I I I talked about him
endlessly to my friends to people to
everybody knew how much I raised you or
just no but like he was just a great
role model and he was always there for
me and like uh you know I'd stay months
with them during the summer and he you
know when I learned my bar mitzvah I
learned it phonetically like they wrote
it out phonetically And I memorized the
whole thing and he would help me run it
and like he was just I can go on about
him forever I would make endless videos
I interviewed him constantly like I just
I don't know I just yeah crazy about him
and even to this day I think
why
why are you not just
more why are you more upset why aren't
you
what is it that you have you not let go
but you have like I don't when did he
pass away a couple years ago oh so it's
new during the time of covet or before
coven
it was before covet right before covert
which I think he decided somehow
subconsciously but no I I don't know
what it is but maybe it was because it
was years of losing him where the last
year or so it wasn't even him yeah it
was like hey Mike where are we going but
you know what's weird is
I wouldn't see him for some months yeah
and then I come back to Florida and
visit and I was with my dad and my
grandmother and he didn't remember
anybody's name at this point and I
walked into the place where he was he
was staying at this nice place they had
for him with other people with you know
mental yeah whatever Memory Care memory
care and he was I walked in he's on this
chair and he's sleeping and I just go
I just yelled at him and he I'm telling
you I don't know what it was but he
didn't miss a beat he just goes Mike
and I'm telling you my eyes welled up
and like I have Goosebumps my
grandmother just looked shocked like
yeah he just hears my voice and pops up
and it was
yeah I mean look death is not for the
faint of heart and growing old is not
for the faint of heart and um
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
better help it has been with me for a
long time and I think I know why because
this uh this podcast deals with a lot of
mental health
um people talking about their anxiety
and depressions and uh we're all
imperfect we're all flawed and that's
the beautiful thing about life and
sometimes we get in ruts sometimes
um our path isn't as clear that's in
front of us we're not sure what we're
going to do we can't find purpose this
is where better help comes in and it's
so important whether you're dealing with
decisions around your career your
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement trusting yourself to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets the great thing about
this is the stigma is going away folks
so you know my dad he doesn't go to
therapy and you know I've been talking
to him I'm like listen everybody so many
people do this you're not the only
person who gets in ruts you know when we
lost my sister I finally got him into
therapy and um
it's just important to know you're not
alone you're just not alone and with
better help you can get your therapist
online if you don't like your therapist
you change it like that it's so easy
it's so much more affordable than
looking up some therapist that you don't
know and going uh yeah and it costs you
so much money to go in there look if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it's so so quick and get
matched with a licensed therapist switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge period it's entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire it takes seconds and get
matched with a licensed therapist switch
therapist anytime for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com inside
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better our help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside let therapy be
your map with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's ten percent
off your first month better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection you know that sucks
that you have to deal with it you know I
I mean look there's always good
qualities like I say to my grandmother I
mean look how many years you were
married look how many years you had him
she goes I know I'm grateful yeah but
that doesn't you know it's still it's
still not you'll want them around
forever but that just doesn't happen
people everyone dies I try to think
about that we all are going to die we do
Michael this is true that happens and
it's hard it's like hard to think about
that stuff but um
anyway so your parents I want to offer
you something like when you're saying
like I don't know if I haven't grieved
them or haven't something I don't know
if he had favorite things to do or
anything like that but let's say like
what's one thing you just would say like
this is him this was him like he loved a
black cherry soda for me you know what I
do
I did not even notice this
but since he's passed
I I I'm just real have this having this
realization okay this is crazy
the two things that he loved more than
he loved his family more than anything
that was it
or tennis and golf
perfect and I've been playing them since
he passed every day every week so
beautiful so one thing you might just
want to add for fun like even if it's
woo-woo you can say Helen Slater this is
so dumb woo-woo but okay when you go to
tee off or go to do your just say like I
dedicate this to you or this is to you
for you this is my offering wherever you
are because God knows what you gave me
was just like the gift and you just kind
of make it like yeah that's like a way
that's awesome I'm gonna do that you
know I just don't forget the dumb
woo-woo Helen Slater so yeah yeah yeah
yeah but he was just so you know we all
have that person in our lives it'll be
hope that just
you know you take me golfing and
he was just like I just love being
around this guy he was so funny yeah he
would be like Jesus what the hell are
you doing you [__] to himself and he
would get so hard to himself and then
he'd go yeah he's like oh that's a good
hit Mike that's I don't know how you do
that that's you got natural ability like
he would just make you feel good he's
always such a good grandfather oh he
would send me letters and pictures I
have to tell you one of the best things
my dad's long time
um she was his secretary executive
assistant she told me after my dad died
gave me this great thing of like you can
still talk to him
and I've had because I hike every
morning I've had times on that mountain
where I'm just talking to my dad he was
so good at like Investments and that
kind and sometimes I'm like Dad
what do I do like how do I but it's in a
way it's funny weirdly summon them like
to just say even like what you're saying
when you're feeling that thing of just
like man I just feel so shitty like you
know Irv keep that Spirit Alive you can
say to him Irv like what the heck like
what's the next thing you know I swear
to God I do this too I do that with him
that's good and I hear his voice go you
know he'll say things like
about death I remember having this
conversation
he was like old and he was like I
remember I don't know how it started but
we're in the car and he goes I don't
look it Mike this is
this is what happens
we we die and it was it was very basic
but he says he says look I have lived a
great life I got to experience my
grandson beautiful I got to have you
know this family
families the the best thing you could
have and he says but this is just the
way it goes and you have to accept it
you have to the way he was he was saying
it to me like I was a really little like
a little child but I needed to hear it
like that yeah and um like not a problem
I do hear his voice it resonates with me
at certain moments in my life where I
hear him say what are you gonna do this
is yeah this is it yeah all right get
kicked in the ass you know but whatever
all right but back to you all right so
uh all right so you're acting and you
know what so what was it like when you
first started getting involved in like
you know you know acting I guess for
your parents who weren't doing something
like that and they were like your mom
was an activist like what what do they
how do they feel about that they were
super supportive really supportive and I
had that dumb luck of working right away
and we weren't allowed to work in high
school but we did you know Erica gimple
was in my class in case Lewis and Lisa
Vidal they we all have worked Catherine
de proume since being in school but we
would do little things like commercials
Erica played Coco in the TV series Fame
and so we that was a big exception
um but we had a taste of what it was to
audition even though we were in high
school and so it wasn't like the pump
was getting primed by the time I said to
my parents I want to take a year off
before going to college and just see if
I can get work
yeah when did you
were they ever like you know it's it's
that thing where your parents really
truly don't believe that you're gonna
become a famous actress
I don't know how they would it's such a
hard difficult like it's it's like you
won the lottery I will say this though
my my dad a hundred percent yes my mom
like one of her shining qualities is
just this crazy enthusiasm hmm for what
you love like she just has that she's
also rough we've had head bumping for
many years
she's very volatile personality but in
that lane of just like do it why not why
not you she really had that enthusiasm
that's nice because
um you know I think it it finally
happened for you know my parents it took
a long time it was like wait you're
doing independent movie that's that's
not a real movie is it not yeah it's not
in theaters no it's not well then it's
not real
who's in it well there's no big actors
in it well how could it be a movie what
did your parents do what do they do
would that work for a pharmaceutical
company and my mother although she did
Repertory Theater when she was younger
she and she always wanted to be famous
and an actress but she interviewed you
know people like in a small town and you
know people um involved with sports
professionals and things like that and
um you know she always wanted to have
the attention
um but I don't think that they ever
really thought that
that I would amount to anything I don't
think in fact nobody did really and and
this is this goes back to my grandfather
and my grandmother I saw like my my
grandfather's book is old what do you
call it a uh diary and big word and he
um he said something like I was like and
and I can't believe it I read a t Rod
remember it's like I can't believe you
know my grandson Michael went on to you
know be an actor and you know uh doing
this show and uh
it was just like the doubt you could
sense the doubt but I understand that
it's not like everybody's gonna be like
yes
you're the most unpopular kid in the
school and the smallest kid in the
school and you're from the small town
and you're going to be famous there's
nothing you there's it just like doesn't
make sense and a lot of people think
they're gonna do that and they don't and
I I was fortunate enough to you know get
out of there and and do something but um
but to have the support and have the
love that you had to go do that
certainly I could tell you from
experience helps a lot
that is something that you know
I think profoundly helps your confidence
and your sort of not giving up hope and
sort of like I'm doing the right thing
yeah you know I was lucky for that that
part was nice it was not the that wasn't
the hurdle those weren't that wasn't
their support was not what was the
hurdle
you know I think for women mothers and
daughters just mythically for a daughter
to individuate and separate from the
mother is gonna incur lots of challenges
it just is I'm not a mini her my
daughter's not a mini me and when you
see that that it really is like oh that
is a separate really separate being we
have different inter we're just
different kind of
it's going to cause friction I think so
I mean my mom's always been on this
Enlightenment path doing the S training
and doing Course in Miracles along with
her brilliant brain
but
that can't replace the actual what
happens in in the dynamic between two
people people unfold at different Paces
you can't make somebody go at your pace
and that ability to really do that deep
listening and respect that
you know you think it's a very very
challenging super hard yeah
that's interesting yeah
um so yeah so there was some friction
that you couldn't wait just because you
weren't alike and maybe she wanted you
to kind of sort of inadvertently
following her steps in a way it would be
interesting if someone does a study or
dissertation on this but those women of
my mother's generation that were like
hey
we we are liberated you can do whatever
you want you are free and then the
daughters of that generation going like
I'm not I'm not quite so sure what
Freedom means to me because I've only
been raised in a soup if you can do
anything there's no they had to push
against immigrant parents and or that
kind of Betty for Dan the sort of what
marriage is that kind of the
conditioning of being raised in the 50s
and then having us in the 60s like how
we so
are individuating from that was and it
was unusual we had to find it on our own
terms what our separation was going to
look like because it certainly wasn't
going to be we're going to be free
because all they were saying is go be
free go be you know yeah so what I
gather from that is and maybe this I
missed the point completely no but I'm
thinking that your mother faced so much
adversity and so many hardships and now
she's like and you're free and there's
it's twofold it's like one you know
where's your struggle young lady without
saying it and B you're like I don't have
to struggle as much as you did I don't
think she I think it was more like
we did the hard work go fly go be free
but it turns out that psychologically
from a jungian point of view or death
psychological point of view nobody gets
out of these
uh initiations these threshold moments
the challenges the things that set us
back that move us you know I got you
that was kind of the Sham of the 70s
self actualization movement you're going
to awaken in a in a weekend and then
you're done yeah trip a little bit you
know and that's just your belief and you
have jargon to replace actual depth work
you know that kind of thing
um I can't believe it's Supergirl
yeah you're 18 years old yeah I turned
19 when I was filming and you know
Schwartz directed that yes who directed
a lot of Smallville episodes he did many
I loved you know oh yeah we love him
Michael Michael
please please be quiet please I have to
get through the day this little French
guy who's he was great he's great
director he still directs yeah he's like
in his 80s it's great I'm thinking he's
still going do you remember
um the feeling you got when you got this
Larger than Life I mean this is at the
time a 35 million dollar movie the
budget I mean a lot of big people are in
this movie they have a clip because they
were filming when they told me that I
got the part I was at Pinewood Studios
there's a clip of you reacting there's a
documentary on the making of Supergirl
and you see me walking into the room
with the sulkins and Timothy Pearl and
the cameras on and they're like
you know thank you for coming and then
you got the part you know so did your
eyes light up oh I start crying like I'm
just I you know my whole life changed
your whole life changed like massive
massively changed how many times did you
test for this
I went in Lynn stallmaster was casting I
don't know if it was once or twice and
then the screen test was the big thing
where they flew me to London and I don't
know who else or how many other people
that might be in the documentary but I
just haven't seen it in so many years
were you intimidated
um were you nervous around big stars
like Faye Dunaway or Peter O'Toole or my
my
singular memory of just the one I mean
so many years ago it's so it's 40 years
ago 41 years ago yeah
um they really did it very smartly if
I'm speaking correctly so Alf joined who
trained Chris Reeve trained me so when I
flew to London I was by myself I had no
chaperone or anything like that but I
trained for four months just gaining 15
20 pounds weight training trampolining
horseback riding fencing
every possible swimming three times a
week
I was in such a rigor running at the
back lot of Pinewood Studios and I met
one of my dear friends who was my stunt
double Tracy Eden Now Tracy Michaels so
my point is it really grew you know I
was in London in this cocoon so by the
time it came to meeting Peter O'Toole or
meeting Faye Dunaway or
I was in such a I felt like I was the
Moss that was attached to the whole
thing like it was intimidating and but
you were prepared so prepared like it
wasn't just coming like now you know
what it's like you get a part and you
have like three days or something and
you're just trying to get those six
pages of dialogue memorized yeah it's so
not a way to work look I mean I I don't
want to get in I'm sure people have
asked you but the one thing I think of I
don't think you even know this right and
you could just say plead the fifth move
on plead the Fifth
but like I always hear horror stories
about Faye Dunaway and I just want to
know if any of it's true or did you ever
see that or let's just say was she just
Intense or something you could remember
or maybe everything was great you know I
did not have many scenes with her so for
me
um what I the thing I remember was
now that I'm gonna be 60 years old this
year wow you look great and so she was
probably thank you she was probably only
45 maybe I don't know we can look it up
but how concerned she was with the
lighting and the perfectionism of an
aging woman and being really struck by
that more than anything else more than
is she difficult or that was the thing
like really tampering with the lights
making sure it was
um you know being self-protective being
I never have had that like I've been on
TV shows forever and there are actresses
they just are making I it's sort of like
I hope
you guys have it in other words you're
saying
they take care of themselves the DP
trust me but in a way I've seen things
I've been in my one of my closest
friends Helen Hunt we have a very funny
story five months when your closest
friends we've she introduced me to my
husband what yeah I love that one do you
know what I always think about when I
think of Helen Hunt her amazing moment
in Castaway when she hears that he's
alive and she collapses in the kitchen
oh that just dropped me that such an
incredible anyway I love her go ahead I
was doing a series in Austin and we're
hiking when I got back and I was like I
I look so awful like I said I was like
oh hell Bill I just look so terrible I
mean I saw the thing I just can't
believe out and she go and I'm like why
do I look so awful she said because
we're dying
and I was like well if we're dying I
guess I look pretty fantastic and it
really popped it for me from that moment
on I was like yeah we're aging I'm dying
it looks like that I'm I'm done oh my
God right that is exceptional advice
right think about it
oh I'm gonna use that forever well she's
the funniest person on earth and when
you get into fights with Rob you go you
[__] what were you thinking no I never
ever ever ever do that no you think I
would think you would do that
um but that makes a lot of sense you
talk about like getting older and we all
do like I I even look to some degree
um you know I don't look at him and say
hey how's I just kind of just let
everything go and then it is what it is
yeah but I definitely look at myself
sometimes and I'm just like wow
wow you're just you're just not the kid
you sometimes feel like or you remember
and you're looking more and more like an
older person and this is just the way it
goes this is again this is this is life
it can't be cancer yes
um but you know I but I could sort of
understand too it's much harder for a
woman it's much harder your whole life
when you especially when you're an actor
it's not especially when you're an
actress but when you're an actress it's
like
you know
um look there's a premium on how you
look there's a premium on pretty there's
a premium on you know they're just we
just value that so much in that culture
and we don't have as many avenues for
the Elder women are aging or you know
but there
is all right I go through this like I'm
like I see all these guys my age and
they're all ripped
a lot of them doing probably you know
testosterone HGH which is fine do
whatever you want to do I don't give a
[__] you know I might even start it but
uh the point is I look at him and I'm
like oh my gosh
man do I need to look like that I'm like
why do you need to look like that are
you doing a superhero movie yeah what do
you need to do I don't want to work out
that much I don't want to hurt my body
I've already had surgeries I don't feel
like doing anything you know what I mean
so I don't want to do this [__] I'll
play some sports I'll have some fun I'll
try to be as healthy as I can but like I
don't want to like constantly just be
ripped and shredded and drinking these
beans and leaves and and it just it's so
daunting and it's so it's so hard to do
that in the overall
um result could be fascinating in your
but then you have to maintain it it's
like the part of me is like shouldn't
the 50 year old kind of look like a 50
year old like they used to when you used
to watch movies like George C Scott's 58
he looks like he's 80. what the [__]
happened to him it's true we've had a
weird you know difference so everybody's
trying to be looking as young as they
can and well cigarettes and alcohol will
do that
that's true that's true uh Secret of My
Success
um one of my heroes one of everyone's
Heroes you got to work with the Michael
J fox he got to work with you but
um
I can't imagine that I mean was was that
up just awesome total fun job show up in
New York City where I was from and easy
to work with oh my gosh dream like total
you were so young here too oh yeah this
is all like I don't know I just
he's older than you right a few years
not that much you look like an infant in
that movie yeah if you look back he
looks like he's so young looking well he
was on that TV show Family times right I
love Family Ties you guys did you ever
watch that I didn't but I'm that's I've
seen a little bit together for a million
years is that the theme song and I bet
we'll be together
for a million more yeah I knew all of it
my brother and I used to sing I used to
love Family Ties but go ahead
yeah I remember watching the moment
where he's watching you drink water from
the water oh yeah and it's just the most
sexual kids drive fantasy and you just
look over at him and I'm like oh my god
with the 1980s haircut and the blue
eyeliner lots of blue yeah yeah felt
very 80s I mean you did a lot of
memorable movies like Ruthless People
working with Bette Midler and I remember
the scene with the you're talking to
Danny DeVito judge reinheld on the phone
and the with the hamburger and that's it
sounds like you're getting tortured or
whatever and you know you're screaming
it looks like it was so much fun on that
one too it was that was those were the
Zucker brothers and Jim Abrams younger
brothers do um Kentucky Fried Movie
airplane an airplane and top secret were
they great to work with so much fun all
you did was laugh and improvise
you know I don't know
I don't advise much back then that's
like much more now current right the
thing to do everybody's improvising yeah
Ruthless People is based on an oh Henry
short story called like
Ransom oh I can't remember what it is
but anyway the writing was so tight
because it's Oh Henry but that's why I
think that movie works so well
wow did you only work with great people
have you for the most part have you ever
worked with those guys like guys gosh
yeah I mean I've been around oh yeah
I've been around a really long time
you're not that old and don't say that
you're not that much older than me but I
mean I've been working since I mean in
high school I did a thing with Amy and
the angel that Matthew Modine and Meg
Ryan were in when I was 17 years old so
it's been that an ABC after school
special do you remember what those were
performing about come on so Amy and the
angel I played Amy and I was this it was
a remake of It's a Wonderful Life I was
a suicidal teenager and
Meg played one of the girls that was I
can't remember what her part one of the
high school girls and Matthew Modine
played like the angel I mean crazy we've
been around a long time wow but you've
seen some [__] you've seen some actors
lose their [__] you've seen some people
that are difficult to work with
and how do you deal with that
you know I've had a couple of
experiences in the last 10 years and I
won't name any names because I don't
want to do that but the hardest thing I
would say in the television world are
when actors show up and don't have their
lines down like at all
and I feel and I understand the family
pressures and the stresses but I really
think the stress it's so hard to make
these things the crew people working you
know one hour television there's just
nothing more brutal nothing 15 hour days
like and then the crew on top and that
thing of just you know if I could have a
magic wand it would be we all would have
better memories or be able to memorize
lines better because I think that really
does so you remember an incident or
incidents where you know someone didn't
know their lines at all and it was
holding everybody up and they they
didn't care I mean I just it's
it's maybe a way of working I would say
it's something that ages me or shows
that I'm from a different thing where
some people just could get the lines
just like that I mean one thing I really
don't want to keep working for is
because it is so hard to memorize now I
mean as I'm getting older it's just it's
a lot yeah and my my focus is so much on
writing the dissertation and being in
school and then you just kind of mowed
into this interior world of acting and
line memories what do you remember about
being on Smallville
that was so fun you do now she had fun
that was great fun everybody knew their
lines on that am I talking to you are
you someone that never knew their lines
is that right no no in fact that's one
of my biggest pet peeves is when people
don't know their lines and I always have
to know them inside out so a lot of
times if they say you know what I don't
like is the night before they say hey
first stop you're gonna do this scene
and we just rewrote it that's that
couldn't be more terrifying because I'm
just as stressed as you can be yeah I
want to that's why I'd rather do a movie
yeah or rather do a series where you're
about to shoot that they have it all
written yeah and you can prepare and
wear your stuff it just makes sense it
makes sense you change lines up it's
it's not a good thing but um Smallville
you did a couple episodes three episodes
I did three was it three or something
yeah
I had a great time what do you remember
we didn't work together I don't think so
no I mean we did kind of an iconic scene
of putting the baby Julian Sands and I
putting the baby into the rocket to like
go bring it down to and then yeah
everyone was so kind on your set do you
remember that I loved them all it was a
family it was just sure it was really
was there wasn't anybody I didn't like
working with no and they were so sweet
to me and very you know that's what it's
about that's what it's about if the
hardest thing and I I'm repeating myself
is to be a guest star and when you come
into a a place where everybody has it
down all their jobs they know what
they're doing and you come in and you're
the
you know my friend Kathleen wilhoid says
she says being a guest star or a guest
director is like being the girlfriend at
your boyfriend's family Thanksgiving
okay it's like you're going you're kind
of welcome there it's not your family
that's not your thing here you're still
testing you but you don't you do we like
her yeah yeah who did you work with
mostly
Tom and Tom and I had a little bit with
Laura Vander Laura vandervort Supergirl
Andrew she was Supergirl yeah yeah and
but it was Tom and Julian it was Tom
though in that third second or third I
can't remember it's too long ago it
hasn't been that long ago hasn't I think
so
like 10 years ago 15 years ago I should
remember that how long yeah something
like that what year was that Ryan what
she was on Smallville okay because you
know we're doing the I told you we're
doing the smaller rewatch podcast I know
it sounds very so everybody listening is
going to be like you have to have her on
oh you have sure but we might what we
might do is when we get there
to your part call me up and just zoom in
if you want to just bli you know Breeze
through it yeah this episode and then
you can talk about what you remember go
oh my God I noticed this it might be fun
yeah why not season 7 and 10 just in
three episodes seven and ten what season
seven was my last season I left after
the seventh season that's why so what
year was oh that was a 2007 it aired uh
November of 2007 and then yeah 15 years
ago
do you think yeah that was it was a
while ago do you still I know you're
writing I know you're getting your PhD
you're doing this dissertation you've
got all the stuff going on and music and
writing and six albums I'm exhausted
here in Utah can I just yes but do you
still honestly want to act
oh
or does it have to be something I mean
how honest do we want to get honest look
it's Honest Abe time
here's the reality
you know you've done it you've you're
almost 60 you said yes isn't that great
if I say it it freaks me out a little
like it really is like how about you're
older than 50. I'm a little older than
50. I'm a woman of a certain age and
You've Done big movies and you've done
big TV and you've you've written and
you've played music and you have a great
marriage you have children a daughter
daughter and you have all this you know
you've lived your life and you still
have many years to go yeah but at this
point do you just say I want to do what
inspires me what fulfills me what makes
me I don't know Happy's kind of a but I
guess makes me happy but a sense of um
do something that has a sense of uh play
enjoyment I mean you know because I am
I'm so steeped in myth and depth
psychology that that's not a light
question for me that's probably like the
most profound question you could ask me
and what I would say is
if you have the Good Fortune to feel a
vocation or a calling towards something
if something is pulling you and you get
animated by something you are very very
lucky that's good fortune
and for others and myself included like
the happiest time of my life ever has
been being in graduate school like isn't
that something there's no question I've
had so much joy acting and certainly my
marriage Rob Watsky he's such an
incredible partner he teaches improv and
he has this non-profit we do these great
shows that at you can look him up at
turbine Arts
okay he's gonna be so mad turbine
dasharts.org there's a dash and if they
want to take an improv class they can go
there Monday oh yeah Monday's gone and
he's incredible he's an incredible
teacher but anyway those have all been
great Joys being in relation to other
people but the thing of the like the
soul work what is your that is like
that's the 64 000 question and some
people might end up just being being of
service to others and living you know
it's different for everybody for me it
was about this this thing of of
education and specifically learning
about myth and James Hillman's writings
Young's writings you know the just
that's been the joy so I don't know what
it leads to after this but
um I don't know it'd be great if like
you could have a mythologist you know I
need to call my mythologist the way you
might call your shrink it could be like
the myth person say about this you know
it's funny because even though you're
talking about something in which a lot
of people probably don't know a ton
about you've studied this spent endless
hours learning and educating yourself
and doing this I think
the under the message
of of anything we do really is is
ultimately
doing things for yourself doing things
it's not doing things for yourself it's
but not doing things just to please
people not doing things just to like
we've talked about earlier but doing
things that you feel whole that make you
feel complete James Hillman who is very
present in my dissertation who's opposed
jungian and has written incredible books
revisioning psychology is one of the big
ones but he would say you move towards
something if it animates your life
exactly and if you're doing something
for other people all the time you're
gonna feel there's a deficit that you're
something's out of sync I I've said this
before sometimes because we have lived
so much as actors where we are pleasing
or trying to get it right or hit the
mark or say the line and that is so much
about it can be so much about what
someone else needs from us what the time
is what the director needs what the
writers need we got to get it in on time
but the the thing of uh I sometimes will
do like no one's looking first very
pretend there's nobody around like
what would you like to do right now just
very quietly on the shoulder like what
and it'd be like I think
I would like to do this for a little
while I'm learning to like fan that fire
of
what would be of what would be helpful
right now in this moment I hope Brian
doesn't have those moments and while
he's sitting here they just go you know
what hey Rosenbaum kiss my ass yeah
I'll be like what I really need is to
get out yeah
um all right this is called [__] talking
with Helen Slater these are rapid fire
answers and questions uh these are from
my top tier patrons
um who get to ask questions there's tons
of goodies there they support the show
they help keep the share the show flow I
love you patreon.com inside of you keep
supporting the show here we go Leanne
says how do you feel about being
associated with such an iconic character
Supergirl and have you ever felt any
pressure to live up to the ideals that
she represents
Leanne is her name thank you Leanne for
that question
um I think there's a shadow part to
playing a role called Supergirl and the
shadow is that you're dealing with
imperfection not you know feeling like
you're playing a part that's just such a
lacking any kind of deficit weirdly so
that part I think is tricky
But ultimately I'm very grateful I got
to do the part
okay little Lisa did you take any props
or Wardrobe from the Supergirl set
little Lisa well little Lisa and big
Lisa I did not take any props or copies
you know I would and I have you have not
well not from yours oh my gosh are you
kidding me that's from
um Onyx that big mask up there in the
middle wow episode
um where I was to the real Lex was
trapped in a basement wow and the bad
Lex me was also away from him keeping
him trapped and I kept that I also kept
a lot of other things wow Kelly asked
the Legend of Billie Jean is one of my
favorite movies you and Richard Bradford
really got into character was it
difficult filming the scenes with him
when he was demoralizing and humiliating
you it was he's such a great actor and
so kind and Legend of Billie Jean the
Comic Cons that I do I would say almost
more than half people are coming for
that they'll come up to me and say I
shaved my head because of Billie Jean I
you know that was and Christian Slater
was in it we played brother and sister
and that had this kind of
so yeah that was very difficult sort of
the very early early Embers of me too
moment movement because Billie Jean kind
of doesn't take it lying down she goes
out on a rampage and makes sure Justice
is served what do you remember about
Christian Slater
such a kind fun Sweet Soul you ever talk
to him anymore not now as much no but
back in the day you did yeah I mean yeah
and he's such a talented actor and his
mother Mary Jo Slater was a casting
agent and she's cast me in things over
the years I worked with Christian for a
year on the show he was always great
yeah great great he's a great guy he was
really like you're a little weird
Rosenbaum you know wow but I always made
him laugh yeah and like I visited their
set the second season because I didn't
do the second season I didn't want to do
the second season but I loved everybody
so I went back to visit he was directing
the episode and I remember he was just
dealing with a lot of pain in the asses
on set and he came out to me goes
I wish you were here brother oh but
you're lucky or not yeah
um right age what kind of stunts were
you doing as Supergirl did any of them
feel dangerous oh well learning to fly
was a little bit dangerous I had to be
hoisted up on those piano wires up into
the sky and
yeah that first time when they're
pulling you up like 60 feet in the air I
remember singing Hello Dolly quietly to
myself like just just as I'm seeing the
concrete floor well to you and the sound
guy yeah we weren't filming yet it was
what we were learning when I was
learning that'd be very odd yeah
um Raj tell me about a time when you uh
succeeded when others thought you would
fail
that's a good question Raj thank you Raj
I can't think of a time when I knew that
other people thought I was gonna fail so
I don't quite know how to answer it but
if I get an answer I'll come back to it
all right um lastly did you ever lastly
well not lastly but I mean it pretty
much lastly I mean you know this is
great it just feels like I'm like wow
time of Sloan but um
you don't seem like anybody someone who
would get anxiety someone who would deal
with depression somebody who like you've
had a strong you know you know head on
your shoulders and you know um good
upbringing but people
get anxiety and depression for all sorts
of reasons and some genetic whatever but
did you ever have to deal with that
I have definitely weathered feeling very
anxious at times I mean I've never been
diagnosed with a clinical anxiety
problem or clinical depression but I
certainly have been through periods
where this adrenalized feeling where
there's a feeling like of being
terrorized by something or gripped by
something
and uh
almost like my fingers in an electric
socket like I just wanted to change the
narrative and not keep
without going into details it was in a
relationship that was to becoming too
confrontational all the time and I just
started to see like for my mental health
it just was not it was healthier to take
a step back and have some space and what
do you do now if you're feeling anxious
or what are the things that you do I
mean the other my other wonderful images
like I've said to my therapist like I'm
like a cat up on the ceiling like
where's Helen then like you look up and
she's like got all four things she's up
on this and like come down
um you know I meditate and I am a big
yoga practitioner and I do hike every
single day and every day you hike and I
think I mean if I were to die tomorrow
and leave one thing to my daughter or to
anyone that would be halfway interested
it would be like get yourself in nature
as much as possible I don't care if you
have to like
drive to the beach or get on the hike or
look at a tree just keep putting your
eyes and your nervous system
in nature
huh
interesting
I mean what if like
I like nature are you Woody Allen in
this way it scares me that you're like
this is what you need to do I don't hike
a lot
um I'm not like what do you like to do
you like to play golf I like to play
competitive Sports whether I'm playing
tennis or golf or softball or hockey oh
dear I like to play sports I like to
watch movies I like to play games I like
to
um go out to eat with friends do you
like to go in the ocean do you surf or I
like to be on the ocean if it's really
warm I don't like really cold freezing
oceans yeah that's not really appealing
to me and I don't like being too hot
there's nothing worse basically you're
describing an infant
I don't mean to like get to it's just
I mean look this is also therapy for me
this is why I have you on the show I
mean but look I get what you're saying
and I do like nature I I do things that
I can't say it's prescriptive for
everybody I just know that there's no
downside how about that absolutely
absolutely there's no and plus we want
to interrupt these habits of mind that
are just Nightmares on our system and
going into a park or looking at a tree
or like right now things are blooming
everywhere on Fryman Canyon everywhere
it's all starting to go
you just just to look at it is gonna do
something to the nervous system you know
what else it is
I like to do things with people
I like to if if for instance my friend
Tom and Ethan and Ryan said hey we're
going on a hike it's not that long of a
hike it's just kind of like an hour I'd
do it because it's with your friends
yeah that sounds like fun but me just
getting up and going on an hour hike is
just seems
Annie Lamont has a great line about that
my mind is like a bad neighborhood I
don't want to visit it alone my bad
neighborhood at night I don't like to go
there alone yeah I think that's probably
me this has been an absolute Joy you are
a joy thank you I love this it's just so
it's so easy talking to you you comfort
me thank you well you're worth being
comforted thank you and you and you make
me you make me think you make me sort of
reevaluate some things that I think need
to be reevaluated in my life and uh
you're doing great you got a smiley face
on your cap I do you're bringing people
into your home you've got the fabulous
Ryan you're being you're finding
Fellowship that's like you and by the
way fellowship and circling up as a guy
having male friends and being that's
huge
I really commend that that thing of like
being in relation with other guys and
having friendships that's a big big
piece to the puzzle thanks uh is your
daughter an actress Hannah she's a
writer Hannah's a writer yeah she
doesn't want to act
she went to Tish she did the acting
program there she would in her own stuff
but yeah now she's a coveted captain on
the Eddie Murphy movie they have night
shoots going on and she's telling people
to put their masks on really
awesome she's very funny thank you thank
you Michael thank you and you guys are
great you're great
she was awesome I love to have her on
the show she was so calm which made me
calm it was just she was very just hey
let's just have a conversation and I
love that they're not anticipating
they're just here they're present she's
very present and I'm sure that's taken a
lot of time and work on herself or maybe
she's just been like that her whole life
uh thanks for listening again subscribe
if you really like the podcast write a
review join patreon.com inside of you to
get back to the podcast
um you can listen all that other stuff
in the beginning
thanks Helen Slater for being here Bryce
thanks for being here how's the baby
how's Beckham good he's uh becoming a
toddler and it's getting more fun it's
harder but it's more fun there's not you
can't just like put them down and go run
to do something real quick and come back
because he's moving constantly why did
you name him Beckham uh we just like the
name it wasn't after the soccer player
no I don't soccer's fine I didn't play
soccer growing up I don't really care
about it at all don't care about
Beckham's a cool name we like it it's
just like a girl would be like oh
Beckham oh I'm going out with Beckham
that's why we did it
I'm going out it sounds like a sports
name now up to the plate number seven
Beckham mallers I think he has to play
soccer
moo I don't know because I mean he's
getting the shadow oh look that's
Beckham
Kobe and he doesn't play basketball it's
ridiculous
hmm I don't know man
all right we love you guys thanks for
listening
um and uh let's give a shot let's give
our shout outs our top tier patrons
these are them these are the ones a lot
of perks with patreon if you're if
you're listening for the first time
um I do YouTube lives uh with with the
patrons um I send boxes to the top tiers
every couple months with a personalized
note
um we do a lot of stuff and there's more
stuff coming you get to ask questions on
the podcast and blah blah blah inside of
you is uh is is is successful because of
Patron patreon.comcity let's give the
shout outs
Nancy D Leah s and Kristen k
little Lisa Yukiko Jill e Brian H Nico P
Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Raj told
me to watch an animated movie and I was
like no thanks it was like it wasn't I
don't know I don't like
um what's it called
claymation no not anime I'm not really
beginning anime anime oh I've just never
been in anime I just never got into it
yeah so when people tell me to watch it
I just
I should probably Watch Spider universe
or whatever spider verse yeah I've heard
good things about that but again it
doesn't appeal to me I like real
tangible like people but not succession
succession's just too dysfunctional for
me in My Dysfunctional life I don't want
to be more depressed Joshua D Jennifer
and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B Mike e l
dance Supremo 99 more uh you know I miss
ramira she's not on here anymore
remember Ramiro yeah yeah
made that statue the bust he also made
the little bus that I was uh putting on
the pot on the uh inside you online
store and those purchased really fast
he's doing a sorority boys one of Adena
oh that's cool yeah so he's gonna do
some of those and he's doing another Lex
Luthor figure so he's a man yeah
Sandy Graham Chad W lien P Maddie s
Belinda and Dave H Dave Hall hello Dave
Sheila G Brad d Ray ha Tabitha T Tom and
what's that Tom
Old Tommy Boy Talia M bet CD I miss
Betsy D and Talia
all of you Angel M ran and C Corey K
devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
yavor Joey M Eugene and Leah Corey Jake
B Eugene Lee how's the baby I hope well
I hope not crying all the time like they
did at the con that time Angela F Mel
asked Christine s Eric H Shane R Andrew
M Tim L Amanda R Jen B Kevin e Stephanie
K Jarrell jam and J Leanne J Luna R Mike
F Stonehenge Stone H Brian L Kendall L
Meredith I can't see Jessica B Kylie
marasalpi
estelanji Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F
Marion Louise L Romeo B Veronica Q Frank
B gen T Nikki L April R Cassie B and
Derek n
couldn't do it without any of you uh
uh we love you thank you thank you for
listening thank you for supporting and
uh
without further ado
I am Michael Rosenbaum from the
Hollywood Hills in California I'm Ryan
Taylor's no you're not I'm Bryce
from the Hollywood in the Hollywood
Hills of California yeah that's it a
little way for the camera oh no the sign
off that's all right we love you guys
um thanks for listening and be good to
yourself we'll see you
foreign